foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's keynote webinar
titled molecular pharmacology profiling
the precursor to pre-clinical
development
this webinar is a part of the sixth
annual event in the drug Discovery and
development virtual event series
I'm antonina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the left of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the top of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract tab from the
menu at the left of your screen and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
I now present today's speaker Professor
Kevin fleger director of biomedical and
health Innovation at the University of
Western Australia and wa Life Sciences
Innovation Hub he's also president of
australasian society of clinical and
experimental pharmacologists and
toxicologists
head of molecular endocrinology and
pharmacology at Harry Perkins Institute
of Medical Research as well as deputy
director and uwa node leader at ARC
Center for personalized therapeutic
Technologies
for a complete biography honor speaker
please visit the presenter tab from the
menu at the left of your screen
Professor flager you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much and it's an absolute
pleasure to be here
if you have a validated drug Target you
can run a high throughput screen to find
some compounds or you can look for
repurposing some compounds are already
known to hit that Target
but once you have those compounds and
you may have a number of hits from from
your primary screen
it's a very good idea to actually
profile to actually see what
pharmacology exists in the cell
what does activation of that receptor do
as well as ligand binding you can look
at activation in various different
signaling Pathways do you see ligand
bias do you see activation or even
inhibition of different pathways
is there an effect on trafficking both
internalization and forward trafficking
there are so many things that you can
look at to actually differentiate
between different compounds so that when
you go into your pre-clinical
development you can actually
differentiate between these compounds
it's also very important to consider
kinetics a lot of pharmacology
is about what happens over time so
instead of taking snapshots it's very
important to do real time
assays so that you can actually
understand what is happening over longer
time scales
so what do I mean by molecular Farm
quality profiling well there's a number
of different assay technologies that can
be utilized and it's about looking at
the different facets of the signaling
and also the binding so looking at
receptorling and binding assays using
various different assays to monitor
different signaling Pathways if you're
looking at G protein carbon receptors
for example that could be looking at G
proteins reciprocating kinases could be
interactions with such molecules as grab
two
and it's also looking at trafficking
because as a receptor is activated it
will usually translocate into the cell
internalize and also the cell will
respond to that activation by forward
trafficking other receptors up to the
cell membrane to enable that response to
continue
so understanding the different profiles
that these compounds have can actually
give you some great insights
and these receptors don't work in
isolation in fact very rarely they work
in large multi molecular complexes
and Technologies such as receptor hit
the receptor hetera investigation
technology from dimerix can actually
look at these complexes investigate
heterization and understand how we can
have hitch from a specific pharmacology
and then if we're looking at endogenous
proteins we can utilize Christopher cast
9 and actually study those endogenous
proteins under endogenous regulation and
we can use that to monitor protein
protein reactions receptive trafficking
and again binding
bioluminescence residency transfer or
Barrette is a technology that's now
widely used across the field and it's a
way of looking at protein protein
proximity
and also ligand receptor proximity
enables us to actually in real time look
at how these signaling pathways are
activated
so we have a luciferase we have uh a
molecule that that gives off blue light
when when it metabolizes its substrate
that is attached to a reception of
Interest we then have an interacting
protein which is conjugated to a
fluorophore and that fluorophore acts as
the acceptor for the energy transfer
when the receptor is activated by the
ligand
the interacting protein comes up
interacts with that receptor bringing
the fluorophore into closer proximity to
the listiferase as a consequence there
is energy transfer you have less blue
light emitted and more yellow light or
whatever color the fluorophore is and as
a consequence we can then say that we
have
increased protein protein proximity or
indeed ligand receptor proximity if
we're looking at a binding assay
a Brett assay involves transfecting
cells this can be done in a microplate
reader and often at 96 Wells but could
be used at 384
and the micro Plate Reader has filters
so that you can actually look at the
different colored light Windows to
actually understand how much light will
come in your your scene emitted from the
ex the donor versus the amount of light
emitted by the acceptor
so Brit receptor ligand binding assays
this was some work
um published and worked up in
collaboration with promega and also
Stephen Hills laboratory in Nottingham
in the UK
and you have a nanoluk luciferase
attached to the n-tomas of a receptor or
a gpcr in particular and that's on the
extra cellular surface
and breadth occurs between that
luciferase and the fluorescent ligand so
you have the acceptor conjugated to a
ligand and that is the the end transfer
occurs to that that um that by dippy for
example
um
you can then compete that off with
unlabeled ligand
over here we can actually see
um on the on the right hand side of the
panel here
we have two different exceptor
fluorophylls so we have a one that's
more green which is the byfl and one
that's more red which is the by 630.
now you can see you get quite similar
pharmacology with the concentration
response curves the difference is the
background uh on the raw bread ratio so
you can see there's much more background
with the byfl
um because it is more green and you can
see the axis actually starts at point
one
whereas with the by 630 which is more
redshifted there's much lower background
so we tend to use more redshifted
fluorophores in these binding assays
because of that much lower background
these bunny asses can be used in
saturation mode and also in kinetic mode
and the great thing about using a
luminescence technology is that you have
many aurism magnitude which you just
simply couldn't couldn't achieve with
radioactivity it would be too too
dangerous
you can also do kinetic work so this is
looking at The Binding across 60 minutes
which gives you similar KDs to the
saturation assays
this work can also be done with peptides
as well as small molecules so here we
have the Angiotensin II uh conjugated
Tamara and giving us some nice
pharmacology
now looking at receptor signaling and
regulation assays
here we have a resting and those of you
that work on due protein cover receptors
know the resting is a very important
molecule
here we have a receptor that both
breasted receptor 2 which has a number
of point mutations and you can see this
changes the kinetic profile again this
illustrates that the Brett technology
looking in real time you can actually
assess these different profiles and this
gives you important information
now these are point mutations of a
receptor but you could expect to see
similar
bias in terms of these profiles if
you're looking at a range of different
compounds and some of those compounds
may give you different profiles
looking at resting assays here with your
exin receptors one and two this
illustrates that you can actually look
at Kinetics and if you were to just look
at these experiments after about a
quarter of an hour they would look very
similar however if you run the
experiment for
240 minutes here you can actually see
that there's a distinct difference in
the profiles and we followed up these
experiments with another study where we
determined the reason for this prolonged
profile was due to some differences in
motifs in the C terminal tail
so it's important to be able to look at
these profiles differentiate different
pharmacology and again this can be seen
with different compounds potentially
here we illustrate looking at the
localization of the G Alpha i unit and
the g gamma 2 unit so two units of the
heter trimeric G protein complex
and you can see here that gauging the
proximity of these two subunits gives
you a readout of activation of the ccr4
chemical receptor when activated by
ccl22
we can also look at ubiquitin so this is
looking at
um the origin invasopressin induced
ubiquity recruitment to the base
pressing receptor two
uh both the water type and mutants and
you can see some different profiles
there
and then also on the right hand side
looking at the erection induced
interaction between a resin and
ubiquitin so these are
these are erection receptors and you can
actually see if you tag the arresting
molecule with our locate and your
bigoting molecule with Venus acceptor
you can see a change in the proximity of
those two when you activate the erection
receptors
and that is distinct if you are having
point mutations of those receptors
so moving now to the trafficking assay
and this was work developed by Nevin
Lambert and his laboratory to actually
monitor the internalization of receptors
into the cell
utilizing various different markers so
we have k-ras as a fragment that is in
the past membrane
and as The receptors move off the plasma
membrane the proximity to the KRS
reduces
you then have various different wraps
which are in the different compartments
so grab five in early in the zone rev
four with rapid recycling
um RAB 11 so it goes through the
recycling in the zone grab seven in the
late Henderson and lysosome RAB nine
then traffic across to the the um the
Golgi Network
now we also add on to
um this some uh some other wraps which
particularly looks at the forward
trafficking and indeed the the RAB 9 but
also RAB 8 RAB six and RAB one so this
is looking at the four trafficking from
the ER up through the Golgi complex and
up to the plasma membrane and in
combination we see some very interesting
changes depending on the compound that
is used this was all validated using um
confocal microscopy to demonstrate
proximity to
established markers of these different
compartments
this slide shows the vice president
receptor 2 trafficking with various
different mutations and it just
illustrates the kinetic profiles that
can be established over time in real
time remembering these are cell
populations
but you can actually see quite distinct
profiles with the the kinetics changing
depending on when the proximity changes
so we have rab5 and early enzyme
happening rapidly whereas the rav11 for
example is slower because that is going
through a slow recycling compartment
moving now to the Brett receptor hit
assay so the receptor HMO investigation
technology
and just a little bit of background
um a group came together Bethesda at NIH
in the end of 2008 to discuss and
establish the intermincture for the
field of precept hegemers and that group
came up with this definition that
receptrama is a macromolecular complex
composed of at least two functional
receptor units with biochemical
properties that are demonstrably
different from those of its individual
components
so that means that except HMR is a large
complex often has many many proteins
involved
structural proteins scaffolding proteins
as well as signium proteins
and to be defined as a except hedgema
just two of those receptor units need to
be functional receptor units
now the allociric modulation between
those receptor units which enable it to
have distinct pharmacology from its
individual components can occur either
directly
or via other receptors if there's more
than two receptors in the complex or
indeed through adapter proteins which
can connect the two receptors so the two
receptors themselves don't actually
physically touch but the allosterism is
transferred
so what are the implications of gbcr
hedge from activation well if we run
screens of a gpcr in isolation we'll see
an established effect for that gpcr
activation no doubt however if these
receptors are in complexes which indeed
they are in the cells in our bodies the
Pharmacology can change and we have
evidence now across the the literature
that transactivation can occur other
receptors in the complex can be
activated instead or addition and indeed
we can even have different effects which
I've labeled here as effect a b which is
novel to that particular complex
so we've got uh we've changed over time
we've we've changed our our thinking
we've gone from
um talking about a gpcr having a
particular G protein mediated pathway so
talking about anti-tensity receptors
being GQ coupled for example to this
idea that
inch individual receptor can actually
potentially couple through different G
protein media Pathways and the personal
membrane but can also potentially
activate or activate a resting mediated
Pathways inside the cell and whether
those arrests and mediated Pathways also
involve G protein or not
um is is up for the debate however there
does seem to be this potential for
different activation of different
Pathways and indeed potentially the
vision of different Pathways as well
so this is of course is the concept of
BIOS signaling but just to Overlay that
if we have different complexes involving
various different gpcrs and other
molecules
those complexes can have different
pharmacology so there could be different
coupling to G proteins in the first
membrane there could be different
coupling to arresting and those arrested
me a Pathways as a result which again
may or may not involve two proteins
inside the cell
so the consequence of this is that we
also see biasingling through
hatchimalization and that means that we
can potentially
um
look for pharmacology where we have
reduced side effects it could be that a
side effect of a drug is actually as a
consequence of this trans activation
through uh through the complex
um we can also look to potentially
increase selectivity because it may be
that in certain tissues there may be a
complex and another issues there isn't
so if we can understand the heterization
and the impact on pharmacology we can
potentially Target tissues where there
is a particular hegemer or indeed where
there's an absence of a hetera to
actually Target our therapeutic more
effectively
the issue though is that understanding
the pharmacology of hedgements is
technically demanding
um what we really need is a field is to
develop tool compounds in these using
these sorts of systems in model systems
to then take those tool compounds into
in Vivo settings to understand the
physiological relevance of these
hetermers and really get to groups with
the role they play in Pharmacology
the technology the receptor
investigation technology that I
mentioned before is an approach and a
configuration to to help us investigate
these complexes so we have a gpcra or it
could be any receptor but illustrate
here with G protein receptors that first
receptor is tied to a first reported
component and that reporter system could
be Brett or fret or enzyme pregnant
complementation or split luciferase or
three or four or Tango the discovery
system there's there's many different
systems that look at proximity
so we have the first part of that
reported component attach that first
receptor we then have gpcrb or the
second receptor unlabeled with respect
to that reporter system we then have our
second reporter component attached to
the interacting group and that
interacting group
transducates up and interacts with the
complex when you activate that gpcrb or
the hedgement complex
so that means that the second reported
component is brought into closer
proximity with the first reported
component and the consequence we have a
signal
this can be done with interacting group
that's inside the cell such as beta
resting or G protein or grab two it can
also be configured uh the other way up
where we have the first reported
component labeled on the n-termis of
gpcra and the second reported component
is attached to a ligand so this would
means that you have a fluorescently
labeled ligand with the fluorophyll
being the second recorder component
you can then
look at a range of different compounds
that are unlabeled they would then
compete for the interaction group and
this would actually come away from the
receptor the proximity between the first
and second report components would
reduce and as a consequence we have a
competition binding assay that is
selected for the hatchimal complex
this is illustrating receptor hit
configuration but this time with the
particularly with the breadth and here
we have the r Luke luciferase
Label 2 is up to a or connect to
receptor a we have receptor B that's
unlabeled and then we have the yfp
yellow fluorescent protein attached to
the beta resting molecule when we have a
ligand that's selected for receptor b or
hechtrama there's three possibilities
um the receptor a are glucomas are not
going to give you a signal because
there's no ligand binding and therefore
no recruitment of the acceptor
receptor B homers uh similarly won't
give you a signal because they don't
have the donor present so even though
you get recruitment to accept her
there's no donor to results in the
signal
so it is the Hedge from a complex that
gives you the signal and this leaves the
other two in the dark and gives you that
clean signal that is due to the Hedge
memorization
just to illustrate some of these data
and this is data that underpins the DMX
that is now being translated by dimerix
and it's and is in phase three clinical
trials for chronic kidney disease focal
sacramental sclerosis and also covid-19
so here we have the ctr2 receptor we
have a change in the proximity of the
donor and acceptor when you have
activation of this receptor
um which which changes the uh the
proximity to the G Alpha I
and you can see here you have the
concentration response curve when you
activate with various concentrators ccl2
now if you add Angiotensin 2 of various
different concentrations to a maximum
dose of cco2 in the absence of the
Angiotensin receptor
then you don't see any
change in that across the concentrations
and this is in panel C of course
and panel d
in the presence of the at1 receptor
we still see the concentration response
curve changing when we have ccl2
activating ccr2
however interestingly when we have a
maximal dose of ccl2 and then we have a
range of concentrations of anxious and
two in the presence of the 81 receptor
we're now seeing a reduction in that
change in breath signal so we're seeing
a reversal of that activation of ccr2
so this is interesting because a number
of
instances
where we have high blood pressure for
example Angiotensin is at the blockade
is a Frontline treatment obviously a
number of inflammatory disorders also
https blockade is utilized
however in that situation it's also
useful according to these data to
actually block the chemical response as
well because even though you're looking
to reduce inflammation by blocking the
Angiotensin receptor system you could
actually be unmasking a chemokine
response in in doing so so if you can
also block the humicine
pathway then that will be a better
outcome in terms of anti-inflammatory
outcome
here we can see there's also
um recruitment to be to rest into the
ccr2 and
in the presence of the 81 receptor are
activated by instant II we see this
receptor hit signal and interestingly if
you activate with both Angiotensin II
and the chemical ccl2 you get this more
than additive response and this is
indicative of heteronization
these slides here illustrate that if you
block a signaling of one of the
receptors we reduce the signal and it's
when you block both receptors in
combination that you reduce the signal
right down and here with that Peter
resting recruitment so again hinting at
this dual receptor blockade
being of benefit
now the receptive for advanced glycation
in products is not a gpcr but it's um
there's evidence that we've found that
it actually is transactivated by a range
of gpcrs so here we have some data with
the Angiotensin receptor 81.
we have the receptor hit signal so as
controls we can illustrate here that
um the age tension receptor gives a
strong recruitment of beta rest in two
the ccr4 receptor also gives a strong
recruitment of beta rest in two in the
when activated by ccl22 however
um
when we look at the rage ROK to
recruiting
arresting proximal to it that occurs
when you activate the Angiotensin
receptor with H2 recruiting the arrest
in proximal to rage r Luke 8 however
the ccl4 even though it recruits
arresting well
we do not see proximity to rage when you
have CCO 22 activating ccr4 in the
presence of rage are locate
so that's a nice negative control and
illustrating that not every receptor
seems to have this
effect with rage but certainly the
Angiotensin receptor 2 does
now panel e
you can see some various different uh
proximity markers that enable us to
monitor trafficking
this is an interesting panel because we
usually see
when we activate a receptor that the
signal with k-ras goes down because the
receptor is internalized and the
proximity between the Keras marker and
the receptor goes down
however interestingly for this rage
interaction the k-res proximity goes up
now
you could be forgiven for wondering why
that would be particularly as you can
see here that the rav5 signal goes up so
the Keras is
translocating into the wrap 5 compile
which is the early endosome it's also
going through the RAB 11 compartment
which is the recycling end zone so we
aren't seeing internalization from the
membrane but interestingly we are also
seeing forward trafficking because you
can see the RAB 8
proximity increasing so we have this
process where not only are we having the
rage internalized but we're also seeing
it recycle up back to the membrane and
also we have increased forward
trafficking so the result of that is an
increased presence of that receptor on
the plasma membrane proximal to the KRS
fragment
not only can we use G printing carb
receptors but we can also study
receptorizing kinases and other
receptors and this is utilizing grab two
Venus as the intracellular interacting
protein
so similar idea here we would have a
ligand selective for the unlabeled
receptor types in kinase II and as a
consequence we don't see any breadth
with our tk1 homers because we don't
have recruitment of the acceptor we
don't see Brett with the rtk2 Homer
because we don't have a donor present
and the signal comes from the hedgema
complex where we're complexing with the
grab two bringing that acceptor to the
complex
here's the pharmacology we would see so
we see
um EGF activating egfr we see
um
curriculin
also activating uh and recruiting this
grab two but only actually in the
presence of egfr as you can see in this
uh panel uh D the the this is an
interesting complex and some interesting
pharmacology that's well established um
with the this family
um but certainly in panel C you can see
that if you have EGF activation of egfr
um that occurs across and gives you this
receptor hit signal
this is the the veggie fr-2 and our
hetermonization with the Beast version
of receptor and this is work from Steve
Hill's lab that we collaborated on
and this is interesting because it shows
you the power of kinetic profiles and
why it's really important to do Canadian
profiles again if you were to just run
these assays and look at the endpoints
at about 10 minutes they would all look
very similar
here we have isopranolin activating the
b2o nerdic receptor recruiting a rest
into that receptor bringing into close
proximity with
um
with with the the end Loop there now we
have
um this label to the these two legendary
receptor now
we see that effect so if you look at
panel B we see the ice prenaline giving
us this nice response with the blue
circles
but interestingly if you also activate
the vegf
receptor 2 with the veg f165a
you get a change in the profile so the
red line you can see a very different
Community profile when you have a
combination of isoprenaline and edgef
165a and that profile is reversed if you
then antagonize
the vhf165a with set of Random
restoring that profile back to what you
see with the isopranolin on its own
so you can see some really nice
pharmacology if you run these
experiments over time and establish the
kinetics
this is the receptor hit living binding
assay so here we have in Luke attached
to the B2 Edge acceptor on the
interminus
we have a Brit signal going from that in
Luke to a bode P labeled propranolol
and that's competed off with unlabeled
Propranolol and you can see a nice
saturation curve there
now if you have the envelope attached to
an edge tension receptor
and you now have the B2 note receptor
unlabeled
with respect to the donor
when you bind the body Propranolol to
that Beast to add node receptor and
compete it off we're now seeing this
saturation assay with the breadth going
across the complex from the nanoluc to
the bowdipi propranol on that adjacent
receptor
this gives you a nice saturation curve
but notice that it is about a tenth of
the strength
of the um the curve at the top of the
graphs on top of the panel here and
that's because
when you have energy transfer it is
highly distance dependent so it's
inversely this is dependent to the sixth
power
so that needs to transfer across the
complex
it results in a much lower signal
and this last part of the talk what I'd
like to do is just take you through some
of our work with the crispr cas9 and
this is particularly work from Carl
White
who's a postdoc with me and now works
with Dynamics
the aim here was to actually look at
endogenous chemical receptor so this is
a the endogenous cxcr4 that's in heck
293 cells
and actually using crispr cas9 to
engineer the nanoloop onto that
endogenous cr4 which means that it's
still under indigenous promotion
we then transfect in exogenous speeded
arresting two Venus and look at the um
the outcomes in terms of the Brett
signal
interestingly we still see a a nice
signal so we have the cxcl12 activating
the cxcr4 we see quite a transient
response and um and that may be more
transient than we sometimes see with all
we see with their expression systems so
again illustrating that it's good to use
these low expression levels if we can
and this signal is is reduced and
inhibited by the antagonist AMD 3100
you can see some nice pharmacology here
with the pc50 of 8.6
Z Prime data so this is a for those of
you that aren't familiar this is a
measure of assay
um
performance and we have very strong Z
Prime so an ideal Z Prime is one but
anything above 0.6 is is excellent and
we have some very good Z factors
for the beta resting to lay with in Luke
so this is endogenously uh expressed
under Indulgence promotion and then the
the
transfected by the pressing receptor 2
that's labeled with Venus
so if you've got 25 000 cells per well
we have a very good Z factor and this is
even better if you have 50 000 cells per
one
now if you compare that to the beta
resting two in Loop uh sorry the V
direction to allocate
um which has a much lower light output
the the factors are a negative which is
which is meaningless so
um and you can see the overlap of the
different points
so this this illustrates that if you are
wanting to do assays
um with very low expression levels
uh it's it's a good idea to use an only
because of its brightness
in terms of trafficking here we have the
kras labeled with Venus so this is the
plasma membrane marker we have the rav5
um with the label with Venus label and
the r Loop so sorry the nanolic again on
the endogenous cxcr4 and you can see we
have this reduction in the proximity to
k-ras as the which steps goes into the
cell and we have the increase in
proximity to the Route 5 in your end
zone again as the receptor goes into the
cell
we then have proximity to RAB nine like
with Venus as it goes into the late end
design
11 Venus in in the in the black Open
Circles here underneath the red
um with the rabbit 11 and then we have
uh with the blue uh upside down
triangles we have the RAB 7 Venus as we
get translocations and lysosomes so just
illustrating that you can perform this
trafficking Essay with the endogenous
protein tagged with the bread donor in
Luke
and then you can also Multiplex so here
we have the nanologic labeled ctr4
indigenously and then we have the the
k-ras labeled with Halo tag which is red
and then we have the rav5 which is
labeled with Venus and using a
multiply reader that can actually
measure multiple channels so the clarity
star
we actually see this reduction in the
proximity to the k-ras and with the same
cells we can see the increase in
proximity to the RAV4
Venus
we can perform receptor hit with this
endogenous cxcr4 tag and loop using
crispr
um here we have the transfected in gpcr
which translates in beta rest in two
label with Venus but the 6cr4 is
endogenous labeled with us and liquid
crispr
we can see in the graph here that if you
activate with cxcl12 we see this
transient response that we similar to
what we were seeing with previously
um
if we then activate with isopranolin you
can actually see this sitting in the
green
and you're actually seeing the the
recruitment of the rest into the beta2
um a genetic receptor bring it in a
close proximity of the cxcr4 load within
Luke
interestingly when you add both ligands
you get this more than active effect
so again
um implying that we have heteromization
and and uh this this is a hedge that's
been published previously
it's an analog ligand binding assay
here we have the the actual illustration
here in panel a where we've actually put
that nanolook in front of the A2B
receptor
if you look at panel B the graph and
panel B we have very very low
luminescence when we have the enlook
labeled A2B
[Music]
when you with with when that's
introduced with crispr
there's a similar level to using
0.05 nanograms in a transient
transfection that's incredibly small
um you compare that to the five
nanograms which is also pretty small but
five nanograms gives you a much much
stronger luminescent signal the the
levels we are talking about when we're
using crispr are very low in comparison
to the normal over expression systems
that we use in the laboratory
however we get similar cytokampy
accumulation
and so we get the same similar profiles
there
and we get very nice saturation data so
you can see here
with panel B we have a very nice
saturation assay computed off with the
selective
um
like a selected compound
if we if you have a non-selective or a
compound that is not selected for that
particular receptor we don't see that
um
that effect that
however as you increase concentration
you start to see some inhibition there
with panel e we see that there's no
effect with the Tamara H2 which is
obviously not
um
not the correct ligand for this receptor
and we can also see this with both Agnes
and antagonists
we can illustrate this with
kinetics so so again we can establish
KDs using this kinetic profile and
this generates some really nice uh
concentration response data as you can
see in panel B remembering this is with
very very low expression of receptor in
these crispr cell lines
and if you compare that to
um
what we would see in transient
transfection of the top panel here we
have 0.05 nanograms
so that gives you
um
still gives you a nice saturation but
the kinetics you can actually see
it's a little bit messy and if you look
at the concentration response curves
again a little bit messy much much
cleaner of course with the five
nanograms with really nice data but I'd
like to just sort of draw attention to
the um comparing the 0.05 nanograms
where you've got some quite messy data
there with the previous slide where you
have a similar expression levels but
because it's Christmas and you're you
have receptor in in multiple cells
um then you have very nice clean
concentration response curves
so illustrating again that the crispr
is the way forward if you want to look
at low expression levels
so I'd like to finish up now with some
acknowledgments
this work was carried out in the
molecular endocrine pharmacology
laboratory at the Harry Potter Institute
of Medical Research
my colleagues I've done the work so Liz
Johnson Carl white receiver Ethan C
Ricky and pay with Donna and Tasha Dale
some selected past colleagues as well
that I like to call out
so I've shown their work here with
harry.quent waniga a number of academic
collaborations
um from all over the world and indeed
industry collaborations as well
particularly with promega with BMG lab
tech this rotation with of course
Dynamics and more recently accelerate
and I'd like to acknowledge the funding
from the Australian research Council the
national health and medical research
Council dimerix rain foundation and then
our partners for linkage grants promega
BMG lab tech and University Nottingham
and more recently The Diabetes Research
wa
thank you very much indeed
I'll leave you with my contact details
thank you
thank you Professor Flagger for your
time today and your important research
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today questions
submitted today and during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until February 22nd 2025. lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any one of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye